the world produces enough food to feed  every person on the planet and then some  yet 690 million people around the world  go to bed hungry every night and 25 000  people die of hunger every day  even in the u.s the richest country in  the world more than 12 percent of people  experience hunger or food insecurity  if there's no shortage of food how can  this be  blame capitalism  10 greedy companies control and profit  off of nearly all food production across  the globe and they don't produce food to  feed people they produce it for profit  food something we literally need to  exist is a commodity if you don't have  the money to buy it that's your problem  because these companies are only driven  by profit surplus food is thrown away  72 billion pounds of food end up in  landfills every year instead of on  tables of people who are starving  under capitalism nobody cares if you go  hungry